So the answer is all of the code fragments
except for the third one, except for this one,
leave the value P unchanged. So let's work through
why that is. We're not going to assume anything about P.
It's, list with atleast two elements. So I'll draw
P. We can't make any assumptions about what the
elements are. We'll call them Alpha, Beta and Gamma.
Actually, it looks like alpha, beta, and alpha. That's okay.
So let's look at the first option. Here's what
happens. We append a 3 to P. That adds a
new element at the end of P. And then we
pop. That removes it. We don't do anything with the
result returned by pop, but that's okay. The value of
p is unchanged. For this choice, we start by popping.
That will remove an element from p, so now x
will refer to whatever this element was. So x refers
to alpha in this case, and p is mutated by
mod, removing that element. So at this stage, the value
of p has changed, but we're not done. We still
have the append to do. The append appends to p,
adding onto the end of p the value that x
refers to, which is the alpha value that was in
that position to begin with. So at the end of
these two steps, the value of p is also unchanged.
Let's look at the third option and see why that does affect the value of p.
So the first statement, we assign to x
the result of p.pop(). That will remove the last
element from p and make x refer to it's value. So now whatever value was at ten
of p the name x refers to. Then we do another pop. So now after this pop,
y will refer to the value here, which is beta. We remove that value from p. So
at this state p has lost two elements, but
we've stored them in the variable x and y.
Then we do the append, and we're doing the appends in the same order we did the
pops. So we're appending x first. The value of
x is alpha, so this will Add the alpha
to p. Note that that's not what we started with.
We started with the beta there. Then we do the next
append. That will add the value of y, which is
beta to p. If we pop elements of p, and we
add them in the same order that we pop them,
this will actually reverse the order of the elements, since each
time we append, we add to the end of the
list. So for the final choice, we're again popping two elements.
This time we're appending in the opposite order, that
means when we do their appends so the value
when we popped x, that got the value alpha.
When we popped y, y was the value beta.
P lost these two elements as the result of
the two pops. Now we're here. We do the
appends. And this time, we're appending y first. Well,
that's the beta, that's the last one we popped,
the first one we append. This gets the
elements in the order they were before. And finally,
we append x, which is the alpha. This restores
the value of p to what we started with.